ja wir haben es eben schon gehört ich
bin ja jetzt schon einige monate wochen
spitzenkandidatin der alternative für
deutschland und ich muss sagen die
wochen die jetzt vergangen sind und wir
sind ja jetzt sozusagen auf der
zielgerade die spitzenkandidatur ist
doch auch für mich eine
gesellschaftsstudie gewesen
und das hat er dann auch nach dem 24 so
weiter gehen also die anderen parteien
haben schon angekündigt wie sie haben
mit uns umgehen wollen bzw auch gar
nicht umgehen wollen
und da ist natürlich auch ganz ganz klar
das recht auf demokratische teilhabe der
afg verletzt und ich kann ihnen sagen
wir freuen uns auf die demokratische
auseinandersetzung im deutschen
bundestag denn der deutsche bundestag
und unser land
die nachfolgende generation haben eine
politische auseinandersetzung eine
sachliche auseinandersetzung mit themen
verdient denn ansonsten haben wir keine
zukunft sehr geehrte damen und herren
und dafür treten wir ein wurde auch oft
gefragt warum ich in die afg eingetreten
bin und das liegt daran die gründe sind
mannigfaltig aber die hauptgründe sind
die allgegenwärtigen rechtsbrüche die
eben auch angefangen haben mit der euro
rettungspolitik und die sich fort
gezogen haben durch sämtliche politische
felder bis hin zur flüchtlingspolitik
der bundesregierung
und das sind nicht nur meine gründe des
eintritts gewesen sondern die der vielen
mitglieder der vielen afd
die auch mittlerweile jetzt auf 28.000
angestiegen ist
das ist unsere daseinsberechtigung wir
haben uns gegründet
da die politik die betrieben wird von
seiten der bundesregierung dieser
kanzlerin die im übrigen wie keine
andere kanzlerin dieses land gespalten
hat europa gespalten
die kein entscheidungsträger davor dass
wir
dass wir eben alternativen bieten wollen
und darum gibt es uns eben auch und ich
habe gleich zu beginn das war im jahr
2010 zur zur griechenland-rettung habe
ich die entwicklung mit größter sorge
gesehen denn sie verstößt gegen zwei
grundlegende artikel also diese gesamte
euro rettungspolitik verstößt gegen drei
hauptartikel und zwar ist das einerseits
diese sogenannte no-bailout-klausel kein
staat dafür die verbindlichkeiten für
die schulden eines anderen staates
haften
das war das versprechen was man uns gab
das war das versprechen was uns
bundeskanzler helmut kohl gegeben hat in
seiner historischen rede 1998 im
deutschen bundestag das sagte er
deutschland wird niemals für die
schulden eines anderen staates haften
müssen und das war das versprechen was
uns gegeben wurde und das war auch der
grund warum der euro ungefragt zu uns
deutschen gekommen ist und ich wage die
hypothese aufzustellen wenn wir gefragt
worden wären dann hätten wir gegen den
euro gestimmt
sehr geehrte damen und herren
und das ist auch der grund warum die
alternative für deutschland als einzige
partei im deutschen parteienspektrum für
direktdemokratische teilhabe nach
schweizer vorbild ist und zwar
volksentscheide und referenten
wir wollen endlich mitentscheiden dürfen
denn damals haben auch die franzosen und
die niederländer gegen den europäischen
verfassungsvertrag gestimmt und wir
deutschen hätten wir die gelegenheit
gehabt hätten ebenfalls dagegen gestimmt
sehr geehrte damen und herren
das ganze zieht sich jedoch fort wir
haben nicht nur die vielen
griechenland-paket pakete die wir
niemals wieder zurückbekommen werden
wir haben aber auch eine völlig
rechtswidrige aufkauf politik der
europäischen zentralbank und das ganze
mutet mittlerweile so abstrakt an dass
es niemanden mehr interessiert aufkauf
politik der europäischen zentralbank
werden staatsanleihen gekauft was das
letztendlich bedeutet das versteht man
letztlich nicht mehr
und das problem wird auch absichtlich
abstrakt gehalten um von dem
eigentlichen problem abzulenken
der wert mit da wird mit summen wird er
durcheinander geworfen wird gespielt
detoniert niemand weiß mehr oder
unterschied ist zwischen einer einst mit
60 mit neun nullen mit zwölf nullen
dimensionen kann man nicht mehr
abschätzen
und das ganze ist absicht das ist
absicht
die kehrseite spüren wir jedoch alle und
das ist auch ein grund warum es die
alternative für deutschland überhaupt
gibt die kehrseite ist nämlich dass sie
auf ihrem konto auf ihrem sparkonto auf
ihrem girokonto sehen sie keine zinsen
mehr
sie kriegen keine zinsen mehr auf ihr
spart ist das was sie verdient haben
wenn sie jeden morgen aufstehen und
abends erschossen
von der arbeit nach hause kommen wenn
sie ihnen die gesichter ihrer kinder
blicken großeltern die ihre enkelkinder
auch mit großgezogen haben die noch
etwas vererben wollen die fragen sich
was bleibt mir eigentlich am ende des
tages übrig was bleibt meinen
enkelkindern übrig was bleibt unterm
strich letztendlich übrig
und das ist eben auch die kehrseite
genau dieser abstrakt gehaltenen euro
rettungspolitik sehr geehrte damen und
herren und die afd ist der einzige
anwalt für die sparer für die rentner
und die nachfolgenden generationen für
unsere kinder und enkelkinder sehr
geehrte damen denn wir sehen dass wir
werden enteignet und ohne entschiedenes
gegensteuern durch die afd wird das
immer so weitergehen und es wird
schlimmer werden
denn man möchte eben auch das haben wir
jetzt auch an den verschiedenen stellen
gehört er jetzt gerade nullzinsen es
werden keine zinsen mehr gezahlt
man möchte aber zu negativzinsen
übergehen das ganze ist schon
eingeleitet ich kann ihnen sagen
derjenige der merkel wählt nach dem 24
09 der wie negativzinsen bekommen und
bargeld obergrenzen die bargeld
obergrenze wurde im übungen schon
eingeführt medial völlig untergegangen
die bargeld obergrenze höhe von 10.000
euro
die gibt es bereits wo war das mediale
feuerwerk wo war es wenn es letztendlich
um afd politiker geht um irgendwelche
entsorgungs akte e mails oder sonst
irgendwas um meine familie meine
lebensgefährtin da ist man immer ganz
groß mit erweiterung zu wählen wäre das
übrigens gleich noch thematisieren aber
wenn es um solche akte geht die uns alle
betreffen die dem bürger über den tisch
ziehen wie bargeld obergrenzen wie die
abschaffung des bankgeheimnisses haben
sie davon etwas mitbekommen auch nicht
da wäre darüber geschwiegen
das wird nicht transparent gemacht und
da frage ich mich manchmal wo da
eigentlich der mediale aufschrei bleibt
die finanzbehörden können ihren
kontodaten bereits jetzt ruft sie können
darin rom fischen völlige transparenz
ist geschaffen und die bargeld
obergrenze wurde auch bereits eingeführt
in höhe von 10.000 euro
dann wird man jetzt sagen wir für den
schon 10.000 euro mit sicherungen sehr
viel zu viel geld mehr macht das schon
der punkt ist aber ist eine bargeld
obergrenze einmal da damit die
sukzessive abgesenkt
das kann ich ihnen auch sagen sie wird
abgesenkt werden höchstwahrscheinlich in
schritten von 10.000 5000 3000 1000 euro
und das argument wird immer gleich sein
das argument wird vorgeführt werden zur
harmonisierung der im euroraum der in
beispielsweise in frankreich italien
gibt es bereits bargeld obergrenzen und
es wird abgesenkt und warum werden wir
das bekommen damit man ihnen uns allen
die flucht aus dem kranken bankkonten
system verbauen will um negativzinsen
durchsetzen zu können sehr geehrte damen
und herren und der ganze trick dabei ist
ja nicht wie der finanzstaatssekretär
von wolfgang schäuble dass er auch mal
wunderschön gesagt hat der michael
meister hat doch tatsächlich mal gesagt
deutschland sei ein hort von kriminellen
weil ist keine bargeld obergrenzen habe
da muss man sich mal vorstellen
das ist ein regierungsmitglied einer
partei die ohne not darauf verzichtet
ohne unsere grenzen zu sichern und jeden
reinlässt ohne vorlage von pass papieren
die gleiche regierung und die führen vor
das bargeld obergrenzen nötig sind um
terrorismusfinanzierung zu unterbinden
schwarzgeld transaktionen der grund ist
aber ein ganz anderer
auch da werden wir wieder angelogen der
grund ist dass negativzinsen einen
wunderbaren effekt haben für
überschuldete staaten und sie sind der
feuchte traum von einem wolfgang
schäuble und von jedem finanzminister
eines überschuldeten staates die zinsen
auf die gesamten kredite die aufgenommen
wurden müssen nicht die verursacher die
schuldner zahlen sondern es sind die
sparer in der gläubigerstaaten sehr
geehrte damen und herren und das sind
sie und darum sagt die alternative für
deutschland als einzige partei ganz
klipp und klar wir sind für die
uneingeschränkte bargeld nutzung egal
wann egal wie
denn bargeld ist geprägte freiheit sehr
geehrte damen und herren und bargeld ist
auch gelebter datenschutz
denn ich habe gerade nur die finanzielle
komponente angesprochen
eine andere komponente ist in der tat
der datenschutz was passiert denn wenn
wir bargeld obergrenzen haben und sie
nicht mehr in bar zahlen können dann
sind sie gezwungen überweisungen zu
tätigen mit ihrer bankkarte zu bezahlen
und alle ihre transaktionen bis in den
privaten bereich herein werden
transparent für jeden ein für die
finanzbehörden ist das von der fall
das heißt aus dem gläsernen kunden den
wir bereits heute haben wird der
gläserne bürger und da sagt die
alternative für deutschland ganz klar
das wollen wir nicht wir sind für eine
uneingeschränkte bargeld nutzung und
gegen jede bargeld obergrenze und gegen
jedes bargeld verbot
ich möchte heute über ein thema sprechen
und ein wenig von meinem programm mal
abweichen um mit ihnen zum ersten mal in
diesem wahlkampf von überhaupt über ein
thema zu sprechen welches eigentlich
nicht hingehört eine premiere sozusagen
wie der eine oder andere vielleicht
mitbekommen hat lebe ich mit einer frau
zusammen also in letzter zeit weniger
aber normalerweise eben schon ja
außerdem ziehen wir gemeinsam zwei
kinder auf der eine oder andere hat
jetzt schon gemerkt wovon ich rede
und den rest erfährt er jetzt von mir
ich bin homosexuell
ich habe extra gewartet aber es scheint
niemand steht auf umzugehen ja und das
ist etwas verwunderlich denn die hft ist
doch eine homophobe partei das lese ich
täglich die mitglieder die funktionäre
und natürlich auch alle anhänger und
wähler dieser partei hatten allesamt
homosexuelle menschen oder etwa nicht
niemand hier der mich hasst nein kein
einziger der ist nicht erträgt dass ich
mein leben mit einer frau verbringen
vielen dank da sind jetzt auch alle
sitzen geblieben sind erlauben sie mir
bitte kurz etwas zu erläutern
hätte ich in den letzten jahren jedes
mal auch nur einen cent dafür bekommen
dass mir jemand die frage stellen darf
warum ich als homosexuelle frau bei der
afg bin wäre ich heute millionärin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
wirklich ich müsste wirklich nie mehr
wieder arbeiten nie mehr wieder in die
frage kommt mir mittlerweile zu den
ohren heraus eben auch schon wieder dass
keine kritik jetzt an die
pressevertreter aber eben habe ich die
frage auch schon wieder zig mal gehört
vor jeder veranstaltung zigmal ich wäre
heute millionärin hätte ich das so
gemacht aber lassen sie mich eines
klarstellen ich bin ich trotz meiner
homosexualität sondern gerade wegen
meiner homosexualität in der alternative
für deutschland und um bei der wahrheit
zu bleiben
ich bin der afg eigentlich wegen etwas
ganz anderem beigetreten sie ahnen es
vielleicht ich habe es eben schon
angesprochen auf grund der rechtsbrüche
und dem umgang mit der mit dem recht und
mit der ordnung in der bundesrepublik
deutschland aber ich sage ihnen auch aus
ganzem herzen
auch wenn ich hier nicht stehen würde
ich in meinem leben einen ganz anderen
weg eingeschlagen hätte ich würde diesem
sonntag nichts anderes wählen als die
afd
als die alternative sind und das als
homosexuelle frau und der grund hierfür
ist eigentlich recht einfach
der grund hierfür ist die zusehends
erodierende marodierende sicherheitslage
in der bundesrepublik deutschland denn
ohne innere sicherheit gibt es keine
freiheit weder für meine lebensweise
noch für ihre nun habe ich ihnen heute
abend bereits gebeichtet dass ich mit
einer frau zusammenleben
dann lassen sie mich bitte eins
klarstellen ich ganz persönlich begrüße
jede verbesserung der rechte für
gleichgeschlechtliche paare auch im
zweifel gegen die mehrheitsmeinung
meiner eigenen partei so viel freiheit
gestehe ich mir ein
aus diesem grund möchte ich auch ein
wenig auf das gerade verabschiedete
gesetz der ehre für alle eingehen
juristisch betrachtet gibt es durch die
ehe für alle tatsächlich vielleicht ein
paar verbesserungen gegenüber der
eingetragenen lebenspartnerschaft in der
ich lebe allerdings und dass es mir
wichtig zu betonen gibt es de facto rein
faktisch für die homosexuellen menschen
in diesem land gerade ein viel größeres
dramatisches problem nämlich die
tatsache dass die sogenannten politisch
motivierte übergriffe vom letztjährigen
vergleichszeitraum auf dieses jahr um
fast 30 prozent gestiegen sind und die
mehrzahl der taten waren gewaltdelikte
wie körperverletzung raub oder
erpressung und wie immer in der letzten
zeit wenn es um plötzliche zu wechsel in
den polizeilichen kriminalstatistiken
geht gilt auch für dieses neue phänomen
genaueres weiß man nicht fragen wie etwa
der herkunft der täter gruppen sind auch
hier nicht erwünscht
und dabei gab es im jahr 2016 schon
förmlich eine explosion der
gewaltdelikte gegenüber 2015 und im
vergleich zu 2005 sogar eine steigerung
um 4 100 prozent verstehen sie überhaupt
hinaus möchte den schwulen und lesben in
diesem land kann es am ende des tages
völlig egal sein ob ihre beziehung
eingetragene lebenspartnerschaft heißt
oder ehe wenn sie sich kaum noch an den
armen auf die straße trauen können sehr
geehrte damen und herren
aber die sogenannten progressiven kräfte
in diesem land vorneweg die grünen also
den vermeintlichen vorreitern für die
rechte der homosexuellen in diesem land
den inhaber des diskurses zu diesem
thema sind diese statistiken gelinde
gesagt scheißegal
diese aktivisten empören sich lieber
darüber dass es noch nicht in allen
spaßbädern familienkarten für
regenbogenfamilien gibt oder sie regen
sich darüber auf dass er manchen
ministerien oder rathäusern zum csd
keine regenbogen fahnen gehisst werden
und nichts darf jetzt die propagierte
jubellaune überhaupt noch verderben
sie freuen sich jetzt einfach darüber
wie weltoffen und tolerant unsere
gesellschaft durch dieses gesetz
geworden ist nur mit der
lebenswirklichkeit und den echten
ängsten von lesben und schwulen hat das
nichts zu tun sehr geehrte damen und
herren muslimische gangs klinische gangs
machen in letzter zeit förmlich jagd auf
homosexuelle und das mitten in
deutschland und das ist ein skandal
[Applaus]
erst kürzlich wurde erst kürzlich ein
fall bekannt wo ein schwuler mann in der
u bahn brutal zusammengeschlagen worden
ist weil er sich als schwul geoutet hat
in einem anderen fall wurde ebenfalls in
berlin und auch erst vor kurzem ein
junger mann von zisch menschen umzingelt
unter anderem von frauen und kindern
er wurde angepöbelt angespuckt und
geschlagen warum ist doch klar weil die
sexuelle ausrichtung dieses menschen
nach den regeln der scharia haram ist
das müssen wir ja mittlerweile lernen
und die rechtsgelehrten in der
islamischen welt sind sich bisher nur
uneinig darüber ob die öffentliche
auspeitschung als bestrafung aus reis
ausreicht oder ob dieser lebenswandel
direkt mit dem tod bestraft werden muss
sehr geehrte damen und herren und damit
haben wir es zu tun
und so waren wohl diese jungen herren
die vor etwas über einem jahr am
kottbusser tor ein schwules paar über
den platz wagten und mit ihren gürteln
öffentlich auspeitschen wo er anhänger
der liberalen auslegung bei der frage
nach der bestrafung nicht so in dortmund
dort haben drei junge nordafrikanische
neubürger anfang 2016 zwei frauen
zunächst nur sexuell belästigt ein
bisschen jahres ist er mittlerweile
jetzt zum volkssport geworden
seit angela merkel die bundeskanzlerin
drei nordafrikanische neubürger anfang
2016 zwei frauen zunächst nur sexuell
belästigt und als sie bemerkten dass die
beiden frauen transsexuelle männer waren
ließen sie von ihm ab aber nicht etwa um
sie weiter ziehen zu lassen das ließ
nämlich ihre gekränkte ehre nicht zu
stattdessen hat man sich überlegt mitten
in dortmund die beiden menschen von
ihrem leid zu befreien und sie zu
steinigen deutschland anno 2016 nur eine
zufällig vorbeikommende polizeistreife
konnte die vollendung der steinigung
verhindern
und wenn ich mich recht entsinne haben
die angreifer gegenüber der polizei
sogar bereitwillig gesagt dass sie das
als ihre religiöse pflicht empfinden
würden
und das sehr geehrte damen und herren
nennt diese bundesregierung wohl gelebte
religionsfreiheit
wissen sie wenn es dann aus dem
elfenbeinturm gerade näselnd heißt das
zusammenleben muss täglich neu auf
gehandelt werden
frage ich sie wo sollen wir uns mit
diesen menschen eigentlich treffen auf
welcher höhe
bei welcher errungenschaft sollen wir
überhaupt verzichten wo kann es einen
kompromiss geben ich sehe nur dunkelheit
sehr geehrte damen und herren
es ist unerträglich dass es no go areas
für homosexuelle gibt es ist nicht
hinnehmbar dass rechtschaffene bürger
nur wegen ihrer sexuellen orientierung
in deutschland angst haben müssen und
deshalb hört meine toleranz spätestens
da auf wo mir keine entgegengebracht
wird und deshalb bin ich unter anderem
in eine alternative für deutschland und
wie ich eingangs sagte nicht trotz
meiner homosexualität sondern gerade
wegen meiner homosexualität
denn die afd die ard ist die einzige
partei die für recht und ordnung steht
und davon profitieren alle bürger
unabhängig von ihrer sexuellen
orientierung darum geht es doch in
unserem land
und deshalb möchte ich ihnen hiermit
einen besonderen dank für ihre geduld
aussprechen bei diesem herzensthema was
ich heute abend zum ersten mal in einer
rede thematisiert habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielen herzlichen dank
nun möchte ich gerne auch über die
vierte kraft in einer demokratie
sprechen über die medien
es geht um die herr man darf nicht alle
über einen kamm scheren
es gibt schon einige die sich sehr viel
mühe geben aber der großteil eben nicht
und es geht um die hetzkampagnen gegen
unsere bewegung eine hexenjagd gegen
unsere partei und vor allen dingen auch
gegen meine person als spitzenkandidatin
und wer in die politik geht der braucht
ein dickes fell das ist jedem bewusst
der hier steht und wer austeilt muss
auch einstecken können auch das ist
richtig aber was wir in den letzten
tagen und wochen vor der bundestagswahl
in diesem land erleben müssen
überschreitet die grenze der
sittlichkeit bei weitem
und das obwohl bereits in 13 landtagen
sitzen
und wissen sie ich betrachte das mit
einem lachenden und auch mit einem
weinenden auge
aber fest steht dieser sittenverfall der
medien ist unanständig er ist
wunderschön
aber ich weiß warum sie es tun es ist
nämlich die blanke angst
es ist die angst
es ist die lange angst vor einer
bewegung deren zeit gekommen ist
einer politischen kraft in diesem land
die mit dem leitsatz mut zur wahrheit
angetreten ist und menschen mobilisiert
denn nichts ist bekanntlich mächtiger
als eine idee deren zeit gekommen ist
ich möchte ihnen in kurzen und knappen
sätzen einmal erläutern was sich hinter
den kulissen abspielt seit wochen schon
wird von journalisten bundesweit gegen
mich recherchiert wie ich mittlerweile
erfahren habe heißen diese recherchen im
fachjargon umfeld recherchen und damit
sie ein gefühl dafür entwickeln können
wo gerade recherchiert wird möchte ich
ihnen einige umfeld recherchen nennen
von denen ich zumindest indirekt
erfahren habe es gibt umfeld recherchen
bei meinen ehemaligen arbeitgeber in
harsewinkel dem kleinen dorf in dem ich
aufgewachsen bin
in überlingen am bodensee in der schweiz
in biel bei ehemaligen arbeitgebern und
kollegen meiner lebensgefährtin
da werden produktionsfirmen und
schauspieler angeschrieben und
abtelefoniert mein lebensgefährtin wird
in alles mit hineingezogen
und wir werden auch niedere motive
unterstellt wenn in einem von ihr mit
produzierten tatort ein albanischer
drogenhändler erschossen wird
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
und überall werden leute nach mir nach
uns befragt freunde und bekannte
ehemalige freunde und bekannte und diese
ehemaligen fühlen sich moralisch
überlegen wenn sie sich mit journalisten
treffen privates und intimes des nach
außen kehren für eine vermeintlich gute
sache zu füttern die spießbürger und ich
will es ganz klar sagen zu füttern genau
diese spießbürger ohne anstand ein
system von verrat lügen und
denunziationen niemand soll mehr kommt
wirklich niemand mehr kommen dass er
nicht wüsste wie die nationalsozialisten
wie die nazis hoffähig wurden und es
sind genau die ganz es sind genau die
ganz durchschnittlichen leute die für
eine vermeintliche hyper moral dieses
denunzierung system hoffähig machen und
eins möchte ich auch ganz klar sagen die
faschisten von gestern sind die
gutmenschen und antifaschisten von heute
sehr sehr gut
[Applaus]
in der sache in der sache streite ich
gern aber durch die diffamierende
berichterstattung haben die
pressevertreter leider den beweis
erbracht dass sie sich gemein machen und
sie denken wahrscheinlich um diesen
staat zu retten die demokratie zu
verteidigen
der nazi keinen einlass ins
parlament zu gewähren
sie wissen dass ich so im
öffentlich-rechtlichen genannt wurde und
ein gericht der macht zugestimmt hat ich
darf so genannt werden
soso aber liebe pressevertreter der
schuss der ist bereits nach hinten los
gegangen und er wird so brutal nach
hinten losgehen denn wir werden in den
bundestag einziehen und sie haben uns
dazu verholfen
[Applaus]
sie haben uns dazu verholfen mit ihrer
verachtung ihrer arroganz gegenüber den
sorgen der bürger in diesem land ihren
chemischen attitüden und ihrer
besserwisserei
sie haben in der heißen phase der
flüchtlingskrise als organ versagt und
sie versagen jetzt wieder genau in
diesem moment ihnen laufen die leser
davon
und das zu recht denn sie haben ihre
sorgfalts und neutralitätspflicht schon
lange über bord geworfen und sind zur
aktivisten verkommen sehr geehrte presse
vertreten
und das während unser zulauf immer
größer wird wie immer stärker werden und
sehr bald unsere politischen
vorstellungen auf bundesebene einbringen
werden
und wir sind nicht angetreten um diese
demokratie ja immer dieses bild gemalt
wird nun diese demokratie zu zerstören
nein sondern um sie endlich mal zu
beleben denn wir verstehen uns als
einzig wahre opposition im 19
deutschen bundestag sehr geehrte damen
und herren
und darum machen sie am sonntag zwei
kreuze bei der alternative für
deutschland für eine nachhaltige zukunft
für unser vaterland für unsere heimat
für unser deutschland das eine zukunft
verdient hat vielen herzlichen dank sehr
geehrte damen und herren